the jogan experience you know about
Broken People when we tried to do when
we when you open for Joey yeah you know
this
story how I got my blue check mark what
happened you know how I got verified on
Instagram how okay I've been trying to
get verified on Instagram for like 10
years setting in you send in a stupid
[__] thing and you send in the
articles that you've been mentioned in
and they would always ignore it and then
last year in November it was October we
opened for Joey at Sony Hall at Broadway
sold out show we were so excited I had
the best set I just had like one of the
best sets of my life in this soldout
theater everyone's like w like literally
Standing Ovation right I get off stage
I'm going to get my camera that's on a
tripod in the back and like during the
chaos at people being like great job you
know you have to walk past people to
walk out and then um and some dude pokes
my vagina vagina like oh yes did you
hear this story yeah so he does that but
then when I turn around to see who does
it he acts like he's blind and disabled
so then immediately I'm like kind of
just like my adrenaline's pumping just
from the set itself and then that just
happen and then I see that it's a blind
person so I'm just like overwhelmed and
then people are trying to like say hi
and you know whatever after my set so I
go to sit with Sarah and I go Sarah like
some blind dude just like accidentally
poked me in the vagina and she goes you
got assaulted
like what the [__] are you talking about
a blind guy touchs you in the [__] she
brings me down to real where I'm like I
have like a moment like That's So Raven
where I go like and I go like I got
touched and it turns into like like a
whole thing oh God cuz now I'm like kind
of pissed that I even let it is the
blind guy walking around still so this
story gets crazy now Joy's on stage so
I'm like I have an hour to find this guy
came Jo
there's people at this theater sold out
they're in suits and little you know the
earpieces that they bring for the
president they're doing that whole thing
and I'm I gave them a description I'm
like he looked blind I don't think he
is myces are he's not really blind and
then I'm like [__] like uh I have uh my
camera set up so I go and look and you
only see the Shadows it's like it's like
an SNL sketch the way you can only see
certain shadows and him kind of bump
into me and like a something happened
and then he walks away and me looking
around but it's just Shadows so I'm like
he has this jaw so we're zooming in on
the jaw and he's like comparing the
staff is like comparing the pictures on
their phones to the people in the crowd
everyone's looking for this dude then
the server comes up and she goes I have
a guy in the back throwing up with his
friend he's throwing up in a trash can
I'm like let me go look so I take a peek
in the back I'm like that's him
immediately and you know what's [__]
up is that he looked a lot like this guy
I know that works at gas digital Lou
who's blind he looks like they call him
gay blind Mike gas digital and he looks
a lot like him so I thought I was being
like gay racist you mean blind racist
blind yeah blind racist where I was like
maybe all blind people look alike and oh
my God and there's
[Music]
like so so I was like it's him so so
then they're like we'll take care of it
and they start escorting him out and I
guess he like gets away and runs out
right before they could get his in his
information which annoys me but I'm
going to let it go they're like he got
away but like yeah but wasn't he so
drunk he was throwing up in a trash can
and they can't catch him no he like I
don't know how he got away I wasn't
there to see it that's why I should have
been there but then it gets crazy but
then okay so then I'm like kind of
pissed that he got away cuz I'm like he
just got away with that and then I'm
like gaslighting myself like did he even
do it on purpose he was so drunk and
they go well we know it was him for sure
and I go how do you know was him they go
oh on his way out he said at least I got
to touch Kim Conan's [__] so that so
then I mean this is like and at this
point Joey's off stage I haven't even
told room I'm drinking champagne there a
huge party in the green room and I just
got told this like by the door and
without saying anything to anyone I just
get up and I go outside I just beine it
for the exit and I'm like in security I
can hear them trying to keep up with me
and I'm like kicking doors open I'm
[__] pissed now cuz now I'm like he
did it on [__] purpose and he's a fan
and he knows my name and like now it's a
problem for me you know and then I don't
even know if I should say the next part
but I found him outside should you not
say this part I found him outside she
she found him outside I found him
outside and then they were like doing to
call the cops I was like no she took
care of it herself that's yeah one thing
about mommy she going to do it
herself
um yeah like no one would be mad at you
for doing that
no especially it's a guy you started
with a [__] slap that's all I'll
say started with that
yeah yeah how drunk was he like was he
recognizing how bad he [__] up like
was what was he thinking well he said
that on his way out so he was proud of
it that's the thing that pissed me off I
would have let it almost go cuz I was
like he's drunk but the fact that he
said that he had like ner still you know
what I mean he was sober enough to be a
[__] dick so you're sober enough to
get your ass kicked the whole night went
different cuz I was like my friend got
touched we're getting Chinese also it
was horrible because when I kicked when
I kicked open the door there was a bunch
of fans outside cuz Joey just ended so
they're all waiting to say hi and I just
had a great set yeah and I just had a
great set so they immediately remember
my name and I have all these fans
they're going Kim and I say nothing past
them all they see is me kick open the
door go past them I mean absolutely from
The Hook from the hip like I'm throwing
a hook open hand drop someone dropped
him with an open hand and then and then
yeah but then there was a Variety
article about it and that's how this
[__] got verified she used that article
to get her check mark that was the check
mark that how I got my verified check
check mark and honestly worth it I was
like oh that's all it took I wish a
blind man would come touch my
vagina be careful little jealous yeah
don't wish for that
she's joking everyone if there's a blind
man in there that's like I've been
waiting for my time that's a dude he
gets his strategies from like a
Scooby-Doo episode just pretend you're
blind well I'm a dumbass I fell for it I
was like oh he was blind that poor boy
have cane uh no he just like that who
the [__] is blind just watch out without
a cane I didn't have time to think about
it can I don't think about the habits of
the blind post show like post show post
touch right post touch and then chaos
dude afterward we saw you know those
like LED balloons that light up the
clear ones that Disney sells Sarah was
trying to make me feel better in anyway
she's like I'll get you Chinese do you
want an egg roll I'll buy it you got
touched she kept saying that she kept
saying you got touched and everybody
when Mommy gets touched mama eats
Chinese too yeah and then she and then
she tried to buy me the balloon and I
was like I don't want a balloon she's
like you love those balloons she
remembered I mentioned them before she
was like you love those balloons I'll
get that balloon for you you got touch
so she literally I'm like say no she's
like no I'm getting it and she opens the
door and she goes to get the balloon and
they like literally like drive off as
she's like walking and she has to come
back and tell me sorry you're not
getting the balloon in you got touched
and so now every time I see that
balloon I know and I was going to get
you one of them for your birthday I was
like no I know she likes those balloons
but it's going to remind her of getting
touched Jesus but now we just bring it
up every time we want to tell the story
I got verified anyways that's the most
hilarious way to get
verified that's so
crazy